[Music]
on this Monday night Morocco's
earthquake survivors left with nowhere
to go and nowhere to turn the harrowing
escapes every house here is broken
and why not all International Help is
being accepted our crystal commencing is
in the earthquake zone plane problems
and political tension how much longer
will the Prime Minister be stuck in
India
some Calgary daycares at the center of
that E coli outbreak get ready to reopen
we may be forced
to go back which is terrifying the new
worries about infections spreading
between kids
global national with Donna freezing
in Morocco Searchers are doing all they
can to find anyone alive in the
thousands of collapsed buildings three
days after a devastating earthquake more
than 2 600 people are known to have died
good evening and thanks for joining us
the epicenter was in the high Atlas
Mountains about 72 kilometers from
Marrakesh and help has not yet reached
many remote Villages this Drone footage
from the azedan valley shows what the
6.8 magnitude Quake did buildings made
of mud and Bricks simply crumbled these
images taken after the Quake show at
Rescuers are up against thousands of
people are injured many others
unaccounted for and accessing The
Villages is difficult the first 72 hours
after an earthquake are critical after
that the survival rate drops
significantly our crystal commencing is
in Morocco where even those who survived
are facing an uncertain future
residents are pushing back arguing with
government inspectors telling them to
leave their homes because they're unsafe
they want to know where they're supposed
to go in what looks more like a prison
exercise yard than living accommodations
we meet newborn yakut and her mum Dunya
kuzcos
of course I need to go back home as soon
as possible because she got sick with
the with the wind and cold that hit her
here in the in the street
this is just one Camp inside the
Labyrinth that is the Medina with the
help of our Moroccan translator Karim we
navigate the little alleys tucked away
from all the tours still visiting
Marrakech and the eyes of the world
homes here are more than 200 years old
and made only of clay and rock many had
been previously declared unfit but are
still rented out this gives you a look
inside one of the homes in this
neighborhood there's a big foundational
crack right along the roof but also the
floor you can see it is slumping in the
middle being very careful and standing
to the outside but this is traditionally
what you would see in this neighborhood
in this house there are 10 people who
live here two different families and it
just gives you a sense of some of them
may still be standing but not
necessarily safe next door is where
Abdel hak hillmani used to live with his
wife and three young children
miraculously they escaped the upper
level with a little assistance this girl
this girl helped me to my voice that's
going that's
some persons thanks
he starts to cry as he tells us the
story those who find themselves suddenly
homeless or scared some have been
offered spots in hostels but they don't
want to go this mother of three says she
wants to have a permanent safe home for
her family and that all of the victims
of the earthquake deserve that
some of the hardest hit areas or remote
Villages high up in the Atlas Mountains
Maria is a small village here five women
were killed one was a teenager a dozen
residents greet us eager to have someone
witness their struggles Hassan his wife
and newborn daughter were sleeping
Friday when the earthquake hit he shows
us his injuries from the roof collapsing
on him luckily the earthquake made an
Escape Route
there was a hole in the wall his home is
barely standing locals have been on
their own to dig and rescue each other
and pull the Dead from the rubble with
the destruction all around they don't
know if the government will help them
rebuild or come check on them Morocco is
a constitutional monarchy in which the
reclusive King Muhammad VI is widely
believed to hold the reins of power
people are starting to question why the
king or the government didn't accept
offers to help earlier foreign search
and rescue teams are now working high in
the Atlas Mountains but with disasters
like these we know that time is critical
Donna all right crystal commencing in
Marrakech Morocco thanks
been dropping ages age of survivors in
some of Morocco's
mounts the earthquake made roads to them
impassable an urgent appeal for blood
donations has been answered by hundreds
of Moroccans doing what they can to help
be injured survivors and volunteers say
the need for help is enormous teams from
four countries are on the ground but
Morocco hasn't approved any more
assistance as Redmond Shannon explains
coordinating Aid is not always as simple
as accepting every offer of help
the desperate efforts to find survivors
as the hours slip by these firefighters
from Spain and their dogs are helping
local teams in Morocco despite the
dwindling hope
there were no rescue groups when we
arrived says the team leader the
destruction is absolute all the
buildings have collapsed
Spain has sent almost a hundred Rescuers
and eight dogs teams have also arrived
from Qatar the United Arab Emirates and
the UK despite the huge task Morocco has
not accepted all offers of help we're
working with American government
Canada's foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie told Global News Ottawa is
ready to help when asked France and the
EU likewise we have not received an
activation request under the EU civil
protection mechanism from America it's
not difficult to understand why a
government might not want help from
former colonial power for example John
Cameron is a professor of International
Development he says governments need to
carry out assessments before accepting
all help and that local knowledge and
Leadership is always preferable in the
short term and the long term there's a
whole movement towards what's usually
referred to an as the localization of
humanitarian response where the goal is
to try and increase the capacity of
local actors the non-government aid
sector is less political the disaster's
still happening Canadian Hassani Sheikh
arrived Sunday his NGO Islamic relief
says charity workers like him face
Little Resistance getting on the ground
the needs they are there to fulfill are
basic food water clothing and shelter
that demand unlikely to go away even as
the rescue operations pivot to recovery
and rebuilding in the coming days and
weeks Redmond Shannon Global News London
also in North Africa catastrophic
flooding has hit Libya and as many as 2
000 people there are feared dead entire
neighborhoods are swamped in several
coastal towns a powerful storm dumped
Heavy Rain that led to the collapse of
two aging dams and that released a
swollen fast-moving river which washed
away at least one neighborhood thousands
of people are unaccounted for the
government has declared a state of
emergency schools and stores are closed
and a curfew is in place
in Turkey Rescuers have now pulled an
American Explorer out of a deep cave
more than a week after he became
seriously ill Rescuers released video
that shows Mark Dickey being hoisted
through turkey's third deepest cave the
40 year old was more than one thousand
meters below the surface when he
suffered gastrointestinal bleeding more
than 15 Rescuers from turkey and other
countries have been working for days to
extricate him
Canada's prime minister is still
stranded in India the plane that got
Justin Trudeau in a delegation to the
G20 Summit remains grounded if it can't
be fixed quickly he may be flown home on
one of two military aircraft that have
been deployed as backups Toria Israel is
covering this trip to Ria what's going
on
Donna prime minister Justin Trudeau will
take off Tuesday afternoon at the
earliest almost two days later than his
scheduled departure and that's only if
his plane can be fixed it's an Extended
Stay in a place where Trudeau does not
appear overly welcome a technician
flying commercial has left for Delhi to
fix the broken part the 36-year-old
Polaris can't fly home without it it's
the latest issue with the problem
plagued Airbus which Aviation and
defense experts insist should have been
replaced years ago a new plane was
delivered at the end of August but it's
not ready to fly yet and is sitting on
the tarmac in Ottawa this debacle is
adding another layer of difficulty on an
already Rocky trip Trudeau was here for
the G20 hosted by Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi the two have a strange
relationship which only seemed more
strained at The Summit Trudeau has been
attacked in Indian media with headlines
saying he was snubbed at the summit with
India only agreeing to a pull a side the
leaders had a brief sit-down behind
closed doors unlike some of our allies
which had more formal meetings the
tensions between Modi and Trudeau stem
from a sick separatist movement in
Canada and interference by India in
Canadian Affairs this is another trip to
India that has not gone according to
plan for Trudeau so it's no surprise the
Canadian delegation is eager to leave
Trudeau is scheduled to attend the
liberal caucus in London Ontario on
Wednesday but Donna it's not clear if
he'll make it on time
all right Julia Israeli in Delhi thanks
there are developments in Canada related
to that six separatist movement teria
mentioned in Surrey BC tens of thousands
of people turned out for a vote to weigh
support for an independent sick nation
in Northern India the vote for an
independent Palestine is not officially
binding it was held at a Gurdwara where
its former president a staunch supporter
of the independence movement was shot
and killed in June votes are being held
in several other countries but not in
India
prosecutors are laying out the case
against the man accused of intentionally
killing four members of a Muslim family
in London Ontario 22-year-old Nathaniel
veltman is charged with four counts of
first-degree murder one count of
attempted murder as well as Terror
charges he's accused of ramming his
pickup truck into the family who is out
for a Sunday walk Global Sean O'Shea is
covering this trial in Windsor Sean
it's on an emotional first day of this
trial where 12 jurors and two alternates
were told to carefully weigh the
evidence family and friends of those who
died listened as prosecutors outlined
how a man who was 20 at the time the
defendant in this case set out to
carefully plan and then kill the victims
simply because they were Muslim
he arrived here in a prisoner's van as
police kept photographers from getting
too close Nathaniel veltman was ushered
into the highly guarded Windsor
courthouse for a trial that's expected
to last at least two months the 22 year
old is facing four first-degree murder
charges and one count of attempted
murder prosecutors say what he did in
June 2021 in London Ontario was an act
of terrorism somebody would
intentionally go out there to instill
Terror in their fellow fellow Canadians
is is it's traumatic this is the
textbook case as sad as it is for the
very reason we have these terrorism
enhancements or sections of our criminal
code get our opening address the crowd
alleged development intentionally drove
his recently bought Dodge Ram pickup
truck into a Muslim family out for an
evening walk killing four 46 year old
Salman azal his 44 year old wife made a
solman their 15 year old daughter yumna
and her 74 year old grandmother talat of
Saul the couple's nine-year-old son was
seriously hurt but survived prosecutors
say development planned the attack three
months in advance alleging Feldman was a
white nationalist inspired by others
including Brandon Tarrant convicted of
killing 51 at mosques in Christchurch
New Zealand in 2019. on the day of the
London attack the crown says veltman saw
some Muslims on the street and concluded
Now's the Time
they said veldman said when I stepped on
the paddle it was surprisingly easy I
don't regret what I did by driving
straight into the family I want the
world to know why I did it blaming
Canada's immigration policies the crown
told the jury they'll hear audio
recordings of veltman's admissions he
wanted to inspire more young men send
the message to others that they can use
a vehicle family and friends of the
victims came to court some sobbed as the
crown laid out its case I think in terms
of a message
it's really just that the Canadian
public pay attention to what's Happening
Here London's worst mass murder and a
concern about what could happen to
others in the future and today it's
Muslims
and tomorrow it could be another group
this is a high profile high security
case we were searched twice at the
courthouse once going in and once
outside the courtroom where four heavily
armed tactical officers stood watch the
judge in this case wants to make sure
the trial goes safely Donna okay Sean
O'Shea in Windsor Ontario thank you the
number of charges in the Toronto sexual
assault case against Peter Nygaard have
been reduced from 11 to 6. jury
selection was set to begin today but was
postponed to next week Nygaard was
originally facing eight charges for
sexual assault and three charges of
forcible confinement the case was
adjourned until September 20th after the
crown told the judge three of the eight
original complainants are not expected
to testify the 82 year old also faces
charges in two other jurisdictions in
Canada and one in the U.S he was first
arrested three years ago in Winnipeg
under the extradition act on charges in
New York that include sex trafficking
and racketeering it's expected he will
be extradited to the U.S after these
Canadian cases are resolved
contagion concerns coming up Calgary's
Rising number of E coli cases as
daycares linked to the outbreak are
cleared to reopen
in Calgary some daycares connected to a
huge E coli outbreak are reopening even
though the source of the infection still
has not been confirmed there are now 231
lab-confirmed cases of E coli and 21
children have developed a serious blood
and kidney condition as most of the
children recover families have to decide
whether to send them back to the place
that made them sick Heather urich's West
reports
it's been a difficult week for
three-year-old Alexander zalm these kids
are warriors and super brave for what
they've gone through after becoming sick
with E coli at daycare the preschooler
had to endure daily blood tests waiting
hours in emergency every day doctors
believe he's recovering but zom believes
his son spread the infection to a young
family member as well you don't need a
lot of bacteria in order to get sick and
what that means is that they can
actually spread directly from person to
person shika talks in producing E coli
spreads among children within the same
household 10 percent of the time it's
why numbers in this outbreak could still
be on the rise it's also why Alberta
Health Services says anyone sick with
the infection won't be able to return to
daycare until they're completely well I
want to stress that the health and
safety of children and staff are our
absolute top priority facilities will
only reopen if we are confident that
health and safety will not be affected
but the source of the outbreak remains
unknown a Central Kitchen used by all
the daycare is only highly suspected to
be the cause on Sunday nearly a week
after the outbreak was declared
Alberta's Premier sent out her thoughts
and prayers while calling for a
ministerial investigation I've asked the
minister of health and the minister of
Children and Family Services to do a
full assessment to prevent this from
happening in the future I would like to
see an inquiry I want to know why this
happened I want to know
if we were to send our child back there
or send our child to any other daycare
facility that this isn't going to happen
again but with child care options and
short supply families like the zom's
have choices other than sending their
kids back to the place where they first
got sick Heather your ex West Global
News Calgary
Black Sea breakthrough ahead what
Ukraine says it's taken back from Russia
[Music]
the Ukrainian military claims it has
regained control of the so-called
boycott Towers four gas drilling
Platforms in the Black Sea the rigs
located between Crimea and Odessa have
been seized by Russia in 2015 and were
being used as helicopter landing sites
and to position Russian long-range
missile systems the reported gain moves
Ukraine one step closer to taking back
Crimea Ukraine's Special Forces say they
also seized a stockpile of ammunition as
well as valuable radar technology
there are reports North Korean leader
Kim Jong-un is on his way by train to
Russia for a meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin Kremlin says
Kim who rarely travels abroad will
arrive in the coming days neither
country is confirming where they'll meet
or what's on the agenda North Korea is
one of the few countries to have openly
supported Russia's war on Ukraine it has
ammunition stocks that could be traded
for advanced technology and badly needed
food Aid
historic tennis title next a new Duo
Builds on Canada's success with doubles
[Music]
lots of Canadian athletes are at the top
of their game right now earlier this
year Nick Taylor became the first
Canadian golfer to win the Canadian open
in 69 years the men's national
basketball team won its first medal at
the FIBA World Cup and now in tennis
Gabriella dabrowski made history at the
U.S open becoming the first Canadian to
win a women's doubles title at a grand
slam Eric Sorensen reports
they were in search of new partners
Canada's Gabby dabrowski and Aaron
Rutledge a New Zealander raised in
Canada only found each other this summer
but they clicked instantly dabrowski
became the first Canadian women's Grand
Slam doubles Champion an emotional
rutleaf grateful to her more experienced
partner even though we faced a lot of
adversity in a lot of our matches I
think it's it's really cool what we've
been able to do in the short span of
time Canada has become an exceptional
tennis Nation Bianca andrescues U.S open
singles title Leila Fernandez a finalist
and the men's team that won the Davis
Cup just last year but it is in doubles
that Canadians have sparkled most
Sebastian larole was the first Canadian
to win a grand slam doubles title in
1999 at the U.S open he and Daniel
Nester combined to win a gold medal at
the 2000 Olympics Nestor one of the
all-time greats won a golden slam
Olympic title and all four majors Nestor
has won eight grand slam men's doubles
championships along with four mixed
titles and and Gabby dubrowski two mixed
titles and now the first women's doubles
Grand Slam for this country I think
there's just a history and I think
success begets success and I think the
Breakthrough that we saw in singles kind
of took Canadian tennis to another level
that we're seeing success both in
singles and we're seeing it in doubles
and just how did this team come together
I've always loved Gabby's game and I
thought oh I could play well with Gabby
and so I just I mean I texted her
a championship team that began with a
text Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
that is global national for this Monday
September 11th 22 years ago on this day
only one story was making headlines the
worst Terror attacks to ever take place
on U.S soil we leave you with tributes
in New York City
[Music]
the bell of Hope is rung every September
11th symbolizing the Triumph of Hope
over tragedy
and the names of the nearly 3 000 people
who died are read out by relatives a
ritual that has been repeated for more
than two decades
thanks for watching
[Music]